منتدى الاقتصادي العالمي في مدينه دافوس
السويسريه يعود هذه السنه في نسخته
الشتويه لاول مره منذ الجائحه العام
الماضي اقيم في شهر مايو ما الذي يميز
دافوس هذا العام انا لارا حبيب لحصلت
الضوء على خمسه امور اساسيه اولا عنوان
المنتدى التعاون في عالم منقسم كوبريشن
انفرج منتسبورد ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ان
العالم منقسم بسبب الازمات الصحيه
والاقتصاديه والسياسيه التي لحقت به مثل
حرب اوكرانيا وكوفيت وازمه غلاء المعيشه
والطباطؤ الاقتصادي كلها ازمات مترابطه
وحلها يستدعي التعاون بين القطاعين العام
الخاص ثانيا الحضور الحضور اقوى من
الاجتماعات مايو وهناك عدد سياسي من
الرؤساء التنفيذيين اكثر من 600 رئيس
تنفيذي الوجوه التي عادت الى دافوس هذا
العام رؤساء في
مرجانسون وغيره
ثالثا المنتدى الذي سيطرت عليه الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه في اجتماعات مايو حارس
هذا العام ان يعطي ايضا اهميه لتداعيات
هذه الحرب الرئيس الاوكراني زالنسكي يشارك
عبر الفيديو وزوجته حضوريا اما المليارات
الروس فغائبين لسنه الثانيه على التوالي
رابعا الحضور الصيني جيد وعلى راسهم نائب
رئيس الحكومه ولكن اجراءات الحج الصحيه
التي كانت موضوعه وترقب راس السنه الصينيه
في الثانيه والعشرين من شهر يناير حتى من
عدد المشاركين خامسا واخيرا هناك قريه
افتراضيه في الميتافيوس يشارك فيها هل
مسؤولين عبر الافاتارس وهناك جناح لشركه
ارامكو طارت فيه مشاريعه من الطاقه
المتجدده الهدف من هذه القريه ايجاد حلول
لبعض مشاكل البيئه